[Musique]
la mine à Saint-Étienne finit doucement
ses jours et sa disparition n'aura pas
trop posé de problèmes mais sans
souvenir n'est peut-être pas prête
s'éteindre si l'on a bien vite essayé de
faire disparaître la grisaille qui
l'entourait tout n'est pas parti aussi
facilement que la poussière de charbon
Saint-Étienne qui demeure encore dans
l'imagination de beaucoup de Français
une ville noire et triste conserve
également une image de marque liée
indirectement à la mine celle du record
de France pour la densité de bistrot au
kilomètre carré le pot de rouge étant
indissociable du charbon noir les
bistrots de Saint-Étienne restent une
véritable institution mais le record
absolu pour la concentration de débit de
boisson et maintenant détenu par Nantes
devant Marseille en effet si après la
deuxième guerre mondiale Saint-Etienne
disposait encore d'un bistrot pour 150
habitants femmes et enfants compris la
proportion est désormais tombée à un
pour 250 quand la population augmentait
de 50 000 habitants plus de 150 cafés
était amenés à fermer leur porte il en
reste tout de même un millier
[Musique]
les cafés de Me repose-paires ne doivent
à leur patron et à leur spécialité
celui-ci tient du muscade dont il a fait
un emblème 80 à 90% de ses ventes ces
clients des femmes pour plus de la
moitié ils viennent périodiquement à la
sortie des magasins ou du travail et si
la fréquence des passages est variable
il se consomment ici globalement 3500 à
4000 litres de muscle par mois pourtant
à Saint-Etienne on boit assez peu
d'apéritifs et bien moins encore de
bière et de cidre la véritable
spécialité de Saint-Etienne s'élevin
rouge non pas pour la production mais
pour la consommation les mineurs de fond
en consommaient jusqu'à 7 à 8 litres par
jour la quantité a baissée mais la
tradition se maintient et si le vin
rouge est une spécialité stéphanoise
commune a beaucoup de café la qualité de
l'accueil est une spécialité du patron
découvrir dans un dans le café de Lyon
par exemple nous sommes actuellement
qu'est-ce qui fait que vous venez
toujours au même endroit
les quatre fois par jour
le matin on boit le café la lettre nous
arrêtera et alors on prend
correspondance à côté alors on est
obligé de s'arrêter là on est obligé non
mais enfin vous voyez balle j'aime bien
venir ici je viens toujours il y a
longtemps que je viens moi je viens 4
fois par jour
pour les deux
frères et moi c'est pour Madame Mercier
madame Irène
et vous répondez est-ce que vous venez
toujours ici
il est meilleur qu'ailleurs
le rouge
[Musique]
on peut évidemment se demander si cette
ambiance bien sympathique de bistrot de
Saint-Etienne n'est pas propice à un
développement de l'alcoolisme si l'on
prend des études officielles un
alcoolique sur deux à Saint-Étienne ou à
au café dans l'autre cas la boisson est
consommée au travail ou chez soi par
ailleurs 7% de la population de
Saint-Etienne boit l'équivalent de 2
litres de vin ou plus par jour et 80% en
bois moins d'un lit alors l'alcoolisme
est-il un problème je ne pense pas qu'il
soit plus aigu qu'ailleurs je ne pense
pas que le café soit un élément
essentiels de l'alcoolisme dans les
grandes villes il y a quand même
d'autres raisons je pense d'autres
motif si vous voulez de d'alcoolisme que
ce provoqué par le café alcoolisme chez
soi ou la collisme mondain
pur consommer à sa litière nous dépasse
pas la moyenne nationale que fait-on
quand même pour combattre l'alcoolisme
il existe comme partout et il y a
effectivement de la part de la
municipalité et une action en faveur des
équipements sportifs en faveur des
espaces verts en faveur de l'action
menée pour les pour l'environnement de
la périphérie de la ville je pense au
Parc du Pilat par exemple dans lequel la
ville Saint-Étienne engage de gros frais
je pense aussi aux actions qui sont
menées sur la commune l'ancienne commune
périphérique de Saint victor-sur-loire
nous avons des plans d'eau il y a une
action en faveur de l'environnement qui
contre balance je crois
c'est ce qu'on pourrait appeler une
action dissuasion
en tout cas le café reste pour les
petites en morts et les gens maussades
le lieu de rencontre privilégié
il faut dire que les bistrots de
Saint-Étienne se remarquables par la
diversité de leur accueil de leur décor
et de leurs clientèle
le café était un dérivatif quasiment
obligatoire actuellement dans choisi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on vous dira que la taverne entre autres
et le point de rencontre de la campagne
et de la ville le clientèle de passage
s'arrête le matin les étudiants des
Facultés de l'être ou de droits pour la
plupart il faisant leur entrée vers midi
on y pratique une familiarité de bon
aloha aussi bien lors du thé de 5 heures
qu'aurait union des groupes de théâtre
ou des associations sportives le soir
[Musique]
mais beaucoup de café sont bien plus
spécialisés comme toute ville
universitaire Saint-Etienne à ses
bistrots étudiants
[Musique]
parfois comme ici il y a eu reconversion
de la vocation initiale du café
[Musique]
sur la périphérie notamment il y a eu
création ainsi le jaune est-il devenu
l'annexe comme on dit de la Faculté de
médecine et de l'Institut Universitaire
de Technologie
[Musique]
2 semaines
ou deux minutes
[Musique]
détournement d'étudiants changement de
décor tout simplement
les cafés de Saint-Étienne ne sont pas
simplement les survivants d'une époque
les plus anciens ne sont pas forcément
les moins jeunes
madame
clientèle c'est une clientèle en
principe de jeunes on adapte quand même
un peu plus des gens plus raisonnables
en principe ce sont bien les jeunes
les jeunes
bien il m'écoute bien alors
pas d'histoire jamais d'histoire ici et
votre avis
et puis c'est pas cher vous comprenez
ils boivent des petits citrons des
limonades alors comme ça et on n'est pas
obligé de leur dire toujours
renouveler la chez nous c'est à la bonne
franquette
il doit y avoir quand même pas mal de
bistrot pas cher à Saint-Étienne alors
qu'est-ce qui vous amène ici plutôt
qu'un autre endroit non d'abord il y a
pas tellement de bistrot pas cher à
Saint-Étienne enfin il y a pas que ça
vous jouez avec vos clients
moi on m'appelle la baronne le patron on
l'appelle le baron
mais de plus je vous dis en plus il y a
le cadre et l'amitié qui règne
parce qu'on peut considérer qu'ils sont
utiles à la ville de la cité je pense
pour ma part qu'ils sont très utiles à
la vie de la cité
[Musique]
en France des milliers de café en tue
les honneurs du journal officiel des
associations de toutes sortes les ayant
choisi pour siège social à Saint-Étienne
il y a souvent cumul il est annonce avec
ce soir à la réunion de la vandoise
je pensais ce soir
de société de pêche c'est aussi le
carrefour de la politique et des arts le
Café de Flore stéphanois quelque sorte
si vous voulez on rencontre l'architecte
la vodka l'ouvrier
Saint-Étienne a ses chanceliers ses
poètes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de la faculté il guérit tout ça
malade non depuis près de 100 ans ses
chéris dit que s'exprime les sociétés du
caveau stéphanois
et qui fait le vin d'argent trail et de
champagne
plaisir de pouvoir
les désirs du docteur Grégoire du fameux
docteur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai toujours envie de
je fais n'importe où
[Musique]
je vais passer sur de vous
la vie des cafés stéphanois est faite
d'habituer d'habitude et de rites
[Musique]
ce bistrot sans alcool constitue en
dehors des sorties la principale détente
des 700 pensionnaires de l'hôpital de la
Charité c'est leur récompense les petits
travaux manuels qu'ils effectuent pour
s'occuper leur donne droit à des tickets
et des tickets à la cafétéria
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les amicales et autres sociétés
ont-elles même parfois leur propre
installations le haut du pavé est en
tenu par le grand cercle fermé par
définition et accessible à qui dument
parrainer est admis à la majorité des
deux tiers
les amicales laïque tout comme les
cercles paroissiaux ont créé ce qu'on
appellerait maintenant à un complexe de
loisirs avec cinéma bibliothèque voir
terrain de boules et de sport et bien
sûr le Bistrot de thé de la licence 4 la
plus étendue
le règne des Amicales Laïques n'est pas
terminé leur nombre progresse à
Saint-Etienne où elles sont actuellement
18 l'Amicale Laïque de la Richelandière
ici rassemble des adhérents de 6 à 89
ans
né en 1922 le billard club de
Saint-Étienne a des tout premier club
français et maintenant dans ces murs
[Musique]
au départ tout se passait dans un café
de la place de l'hôtel de ville à
présent le billard club partage ses
salles avec les fils athéistes les
basketteurs et les parachutistes mais
tout le monde peut y consommer
c'est un lieu public où chacun peut
profiter dans la limite des places
disponibles des installations et jeux de
l'association
le libre accès au bar d'une association
est également un moyen de redorer son
blason par un apport d'argent frais
mais baveux entendait par là les adeptes
de la sarbacane ont ainsi leur public
même à l'entraînement
je pense que si les gens choisissent
leur consommation
en prenant des boissons non alcoolisées
telles que des jus de fruits ou des eaux
toutes sortes et bien ce n'est pas
regrettable qu'il y a des cafés car ils
sont utiles dans la vie d'une cité ils
permettent des rapports faciles il est
évident que nous devons surveiller dans
les cafés l'application de la
législation en vigueur par exemple par
rapport à l'alcoolisme des mineurs je
dois dire que dans quelques cas le
comité a même demandé la fermeture
certains établissements qui ne
respectaient pas cette loi nous avons en
contact permanent avec
qui nous met en garde de ne pas servir
de l'alcool au mineur il est certain que
il se trouve encore des cafés qui
servent des boissons alcoolisées
aux jeunes évidemment ceci ça va quoi il
s'expose et peut-être pas toujours
pourtant Dieu sait s'ils sont
s'ils sont informés de ce côté là
personnellement je sais pas alcoolique
mais
je sais pas
[Musique]
trop souvent
les cafés pour me saouler et il est
certain et ça je m'insurge un peu là
dessus parce que
les boissons dans notre Colisée sont
empêcher c'est évident bien que je pense
que c'est pas forcément dans un bistrot
que les gars va boire de l'alcool
les boissons sans alcool sont maintenant
les plus vendus mais l'alcool chez les
jeunes fait toujours davantage de
ravages que la drogue il est à l'origine
des bagarres dans la rue à la sortie des
balles et quand un homme est arrêté pour
un délivre évoqué par l'ivresse le
patron du café où il a bu et rarement
convoqué au tribunal dans ce sens il
pourrait y avoir répression pour le
reste c'est une question d'éducation et
de choix dans les loisirs
lieu de rencontre relativement nouveau
en France les maisons des jeunes une
douzaine à Saint-Étienne offre des
salles de réunion des bars où l'on voit
des jus de fruits et des activités
choisis généralement par les jeunes
eux-mêmes
[Musique]
parfois même l'intérêt d'un groupe
arrive à ce cristalliser sur une
activité qu'il réussit particulièrement
bien et ce qui était un simple loisir au
départ quand un sens nouveau avec un
esprit d'équipe
[Musique]
je ne partage pas ce point de vue je
pense que c'est un établissement c'est
un monument de la ville c'est au lieu de
la ville si vous voulez où chaque
tendance à condition que les gens qui
viennent respectent le patrimoine commun
la Maison de la Culture à côté fort cher
à l'ensemble des contribuables et il est
normal que tous ceux qui viennent
respectent les installations qui ont été
faites moyennes en quoi mais dans cette
courtoisie ce respect du bien public
tout le monde est admis quel que soit sa
philosophie notre part on avance aussi
un chiffre de 800 millions pour la
Maison de la Culture et certains jeunes
encore disent ce qui serait pas
souhaitable d'avoir davantage
d'animateurs de quartier peut-être
davantage de maison jeunes mais surtout
davantage animateurs qu'est-ce que vous
pensez faire c'est une question qui peut
discuter mais je pense si vous voulez
que l'effort de la ville pour ses
diverses activités et proportionnelles
finales finalement à l'importance de
chacune d'elles on ne peut pas comparer
le budget de la Maison de la Culture
budget qui est en partie compensé par
des recettes qui ne sont loin d'être
négligeables avec le budget d'une maison
de jeunes est-ce que vous pensez
souhaitable néanmoins d'augmenter le
nombre d'animateurs de quartiers ces
fonctions des ressources de la ville
mais je pense effectivement qu'il est
souhaitable dans la mesure où on le peut
[Musique]
ne remplacera le bistrot et
qui drague le problème de l'alcoolisme à
l'inverse le café n'est pas le seul lieu
d'animation spontanée l'animation d'une
ville est un tout je pense que
l'animation d'une ville c'est l'affaire
de tous ces citoyens nous sommes grand
village Saint-Etienne nous souhaitons
que les initiatives viennent vraiment de
la base et à partir du moment elles sont
reconnues comme étant de valeurs elles
sont aidées en fait la force du bistrot
est de constituer un lieu d'animation
permanente parfois même s'il est vide il
suffit de la gaieter du frein parler de
la tension complaisante d'une seule
personne je suis persuadé que le jour où
l'autre le baron et la baronne
disparaîtront même si d'autres prennent
le bon pichet ce sera plus beau Pichon
puis c'est tout ma ville moi je suis
j'ai commencé dans le café j'avais 23
ans et j'en ai 73 alors vous rendez
compte ça fait 50 ans rentrer dans le
métier alors on peut rien m'apprendre
j'ai ça dans le sang moi alors je suis
maman était
eltona bistro j'ai vécu dans cette
ambiance et je l'ai toujours conservé
pour moi et moi c'est ma ville vous
comprenez et je crois que le jour où je
partirai et ben je sais pas si je serai
vraiment ennuyé et je crois que ce
serait ma fin quoi je crois que je veux
passer vraiment pour partiriez
le travail que je me farci là
73 ans
c'est pour cela que des bistrots
accueillent encore les hommes là où il
cherche l'évasion
c'est pour cela qu'il manque dans les
cités modernes car à l'exception des
cafés préservés par les constructions en
règle générale il ne peut être servi de
boissons alcoolisées à moins de 100
mètres d'un bâtiment public et c'est
ainsi que le préfet de la Loire a été
conduit récemment à ramener de 100 à 50
mètres la distance minimum dans une zone
de rénovation urbaine
le bistrot fait encore partie de la vie
quotidienne de beaucoup et il reste pour
certains l'un des seuls moyens de
communication
[Musique]
en arabe on est sûr de trouver des
soignants
[Musique]
[Rires]
c'est bien
tout le monde
les Espagnols
[Musique]